From what I've seen, I wonder if the thieves in this area have destroyed themselves
Ryoshu-san seems to see me as a danger.
In today's religion, Kubo is a sacred creature,
and it seems that there was a pearl that was used only by the gods.
It's true that I'm a relative of the Demon King, but I'm more of a Demon King now
.  Lukakuru
God
please help science
a help me a I'm not a divine beast If you're not a newcomer you're wrong I'm not good at it
Ah
[music]
I'll try as much as I
can Say liver cancer
It's like I ate something strange because I was in trouble, and my
mother is also a professional, so
please fix my free time.
Here you go,
big command
will do good deeds
[music]